في سوريا بعد الزلزال المدمر لا شيء صالحا
للحياه ولا احد يساعد كذلك الاستئناف
الحياه في البلد المنكوب بالحرب اصلا فشل
السياسيون في تنحيه خلافاتهم جانبا فنعكس
ذلك كازمه جديده على المتضررين بعد اسبوع
على ارسال الاداره الذاتيه الكرديه
لمساعدات الى مناطق الشمال الغربي السوري
لم تسمح فصائل المعارضه المواليه لتركيا
بدخول هذه المساعدات واليوم تعلن الاداره
الذاتيه الكرديه انها ستعيد المساعدات الى
مناطقها بعد هذه الاعاقه ولا احد متضررا
الا السوريون
وعليه وفي الوقت الذي نؤكد نحن في الاداره
الذاتيه لشمال وشرق سوريا على ان هذا
الموقف غير ان هذه المواقف غير صحيحه
وتزيد من معاناه المتضررين وتجعل معانتهم
مصنفه تحت بنود ومواقف سياسيه
نرفضها نحن فاننا وبكل اسف وبعد مرور اكثر
من سبع ايام على اعاقه وصول دعمنا
المتضررين سنقوم بسحب المواد التي كانت
على معبر ام جلود والمجهزه لادخالها
للمناطق المتضرره
بتمنى انه بس هلا شويه تاجيل مشان المدرسه
احنا هلا باركين فيها لانه ما عندنا بيوت
يعني هلا صفينا ان احنا بس بالمدارس قلنا
يعني هلا بيوتنا نستقر فيها طاول طاول
بدايه تتهبطت يعني
من بدنا نرجع على البيوت اللي بده يعطونا
اياها عشان نامن الاطفال انه ترجع المدارس
هلا بتاجر فحوصات شوي يعني كلها تتاجل شوي
المدارس مشان هالاطفال